[Music]
on this saturday night the final push
police close in on the heart of the
protest in the nation's capital we are
in this until it is over
the response from police parliament and
the protesters for my rights i'll do
anything i'll get pepper sprayed every
single second
on the brink of war we do not know what
will happen but the risk
for conflict is real russia launches
nuclear exercises as ukraine's president
demands new security guarantees from
western allies plus raising the bar an
olympic controversy sparks debate over
athlete age limits
global national
reporting tonight
jeff
[Applause]
semple will be arrested
police and protesters faced off for a
second straight day in the nation's
capital and at times those tensions
erupted into violence but tonight it
appears the ottawa occupation is now
into its final hours good evening and
thank you for joining us police and
protesters are accusing each other of
abusive behavior after a day that saw
officers reclaim the street in front of
parliament hill at least 170 people have
been arrested as part of the convoy
crackdown and ottawa's police chief
warned their investigation into others
involved will continue for many months
david aiken spent the day reporting from
the protest and joins us now from
parliament hill david well jeff the
battle of wellington street in front of
the parliament buildings is over it took
three weeks but police have cleared the
street and the trucks and the protesters
well they're gone
hundreds of police officers began the
final push early saturday morning many
wearing helmets and carrying wooden
batons against a few hundred protesters
some of whom were wearing body armor
said police
some protesters also had smoke grenades
which they used against the police line
but police did employ riot control
techniques including loud bangs to scare
and disorient protesters i think
that's the turning point that we need to
see
slowly methodically over several hours
police pushed protesters back officers
from municipal forces in vancouver
calgary toronto and elsewhere assisting
we are in this until it is over every
one of our police agency partners has
indicated their continued and ongoing
support to work with us to finish this
unlawful occupation
many would not leave voluntarily and
more than 50 were arrested saturday some
had to be subdued with pepper spray
police say they will review any
complaints of excessive force but the
chief also says
those protesters were warned we also
indicated that we would escalate and
forcefully remove people from the
streets if they did not comply
nonetheless some brought their children
to the front lines of the confrontation
which is itself a violation of the
federal emergencies act
many drivers got the message and took
their vehicles off the hill under their
own steam but some drivers locked
themselves in their cabs and after
receiving multiple warnings from police
were forced out
then the towing began and all of this
took place in front of west block where
in the house of commons mps spent the
day debating the use of the federal
emergencies act mps will continue debate
sunday before voting on monday
citing that act banks had as of saturday
frozen 76 accounts with a combined 3.2
million dollars in them that authorities
say was to be used to support the
occupation as human beings we make
choices
one of those whose account was frozen
protest organizer tamera leach arrested
thursday night but in court in ottawa
today where she told the judge she's
unable to pay a 1700 hotel bill leach
will stay behind bars at least until
tuesday morning when the judge will
decide if she can be released on bail
please step out of the vehicle sir
it was the same with pat king of red
deer alberta another convoy organizer he
was in court saturday but he'll stay in
jail till his bail hearing concludes
tuesday but one of the convoy organizers
is free chris barber was released
yesterday on a hundred thousand dollars
of bail and a promise to go to his home
in swift current saskatchewan jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
well police continue their operation in
the downtown core as you can see the
streets of the city are beginning to
look more bare and normal our sean
o'shea has been in the midst of that
police operation again today so sean how
are things looking from your vantage
point
well jeff take a look right now what
we're seeing so right behind me is an
ottawa police car we've got the opp the
ottawa police and we've got concrete
barricades and fences and these have
gone up all through the day basically
ringing this center of the city
including parliament the shadow laurier
hotel getting in to the core of the city
is not easy there are a hundred
checkpoints in and around ottawa police
are asking people what their purpose is
to come in here and that's because
they're still in the midst of trying to
clean up this protest trying to get rid
of those trucks either by towing them
away or by asking the drivers to drive
them away police out in full force again
here today as you were hearing and this
operation is continuing through the day
we're probably going to see this go on
for a day or two or more from now jeff
right and i understand earlier in the
day sean you were speaking with some of
the remaining protesters what are you
hearing from them today
jeff there was a sense of you know it's
coming to an end but many came up to us
to talk about what they hoped people
would remember from this protest that
they weren't all bad guys even though a
lot of people in the city here don't
lament the fact that they're leaving
here's what a couple told us
we are hard-working canadians we pay
taxes
like why can't we have open dialogue you
be the light yes be the light talk
you tell them that there are people here
who are here for the right reasons to
fix canada
when he said we're going to watch he was
talking about watching our broadcast
watching our story because
most of these protesters came up to us
and said you're not telling the truth we
said hey watch the stories and then
judge us jeff
all right our truth-teller shawn o'shea
in ottawa tonight thanks sean from
protesters to police officers appeared
to be shifting strategy today as police
worked to clear the remaining protesters
from the area the slow methodical
approach that we saw from police
yesterday seemed to be replaced with a
much tougher line today our auto bureau
chief mercedes stevenson has been on the
ground today so mercedes what did you
make of the police tactics you saw today
jeff it felt very different from
yesterday where things started out very
slowly the officers who were on the
front line yesterday were just in their
regular uniforms they didn't have
additional body armor helmets on today
it was clear there was a different tone
being set the officers who came out
were wearing riot gear they were on the
front lines and they were carrying large
wooden batons with them which they were
using to strike people if they didn't
move back when the police line moved
forward they also had gas masks in some
cases and eventually the line that i got
pushed back by
on a side street here had full-blown gas
masks under riot helmets which led
people to believe they were going to be
gassed that never happened by the way
despite social media reports about it
there was a much faster pace that was
undertaken by the officers
it was more aggressive and there was a
harder element right behind them the
emergency response team who are tactical
officers with the rcmp very elite unit
were being used to clear out the tents
and also being used to clear out the
trucks and they had their weapons out
and drawn
i did not see them pointing them at
anybody but it certainly was a much more
aggressive presence and it was much more
rapid they cleared all of wellington
street in the side streets in a day in
something that experts thought might
take as long as a week to do yeah we
heard a statement from the police chief
earlier citing concerns about
misinformation disinformation
circulating on social media how would
you describe you know what you're seeing
online versus the reality there on the
ground
yeah there was some people alleging
police brutality i didn't see that i did
see people absolutely getting hit by
batons and some rough arrests those were
people who did not move back as the
police line advanced sometimes they were
on their knees
begging with officers some veterans
saying please don't do this but if you
did not move when they told you to move
that was the fate that you suffered
there was no gas used nobody was shot
there was not mass arrests at gun points
despite what a new york times headline
appeared to report and most importantly
no one died because there was a false
report on american news that a woman was
trampled by a horse yesterday that did
not happen that was confirmed by both
police and ems but the police chief did
talk today about the problem they've had
with misinformation and disinformation
this is what he had to say
one of the tactics that the protesters
and demonstrators are using is
misinformation
information that is inaccurate
information that misleads the public
we're actively tweeting and providing
information out in through social media
and other media
mechanisms in order to be able to try
and get accurate factual information
around what is going on within the
protest
so jeff certainly a more aggressive
police presence and the possibility you
could get hurt if you did not move back
when the police instructed you to but
nothing like some of the other riot
police i've seen in action in the past
including at the g7 g20 which was much
more aggressive tactics
mercedes-stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes
and protests supporting that ottawa
occupation are once again taking place
at several sites across the country a
convoy forced the closure of the pacific
highway crossing in british columbia and
in quebec police say at least three
people were arrested as protesters
packed the streets of quebec city
amid heavy snow a convoy made its way to
quebec's national assembly where
thousands gathered to hear speeches
calling for the immediate end to all
pandemic public health measures
meanwhile an ontario judge has just
extended an order to keep the ambassador
bridge clear of protesters the
injunction prohibits blocking access to
the span that connects windsor with
detroit indefinitely this comes after
demonstrators blocked traffic at north
america's busiest border crossing for
nearly a week the previous order was set
to expire on monday
turning now to the escalating tensions
in ukraine and a new show of force from
vladimir putin the russian president
oversaw large-scale nuclear drills today
and as reggie takini reports it comes as
ukraine's president issues a desperate
plea to western allies
it's an intimidation tactic to the
maximum degree
russia carrying out nuclear drills on
saturday in a test of its military
capabilities coming as it's amassed more
personnel on ukraine's border
the u.s believes russia is prepared to
strike further pulling back the curtain
on intelligence to expose russia's game
play in real time we do not know what
will happen but the risk for conflict is
real the threat is a central focus with
nato allies and g7 nations who see
rules-based order under attack promising
russia will pay if it crosses a line we
have prepared
together economic measures
that will be
swift
severe
and united while the threat of sanctions
has yet to deter russia fearlessness
might despite his country under the
shadow of assault volodomir zielinski
left keeve to bring his concerns to a
global stage in germany president
asking for a meeting with russia's
leader admitting he doesn't know what
vladimir putin wants william taylor
america's former ambassador to ukraine
says if putin advances whatever he
claims is a victory won't be tolerated
russia will be a pariah
president putin will be probably a war
criminal this will be something that he
will lose in history
in the breakaway regions of ukraine
conflict is only growing worse there
have been hundreds of reported ceasefire
violations
the separatist leader calling for full
mobilization against ukrainian
aggression
the u.s embassy says russia is
propagating violence and rebel-backed
territory they control that's already
left some ukrainian soldiers dead
furthering concerns that the kremlin is
drafting a pretext they're looking for a
justification looking for some rationale
to try to convince the world that there
is some reason for this invasion and
that's led to further calls from ukraine
to have nato put a timeline on the table
the potential membership arguing it
won't sit as a buffer between the west
and russia until then it will rely on
nato supplies to defend its democracy
which includes another shipment of
lethal aid that arrived from canada on
saturday
jeff
reggie cicchini in washington thanks
reggie
coming up racism in the workplace
hundreds of canadian ceos recently
promised to improve racial equality but
have they delivered the answer next
george floyd's murder in the summer of
2020 sparked a global outcry over
systemic racial inequality including
from black employees in corporate canada
a new survey sheds light on how their
situation is changing and gaviola
reports
[Applause]
the chorus of voices demanding social
justice and change as the black lives
matter movement gained momentum rang
loud and clear in 2020 it spurred
promises for major firms across canada
to do better more than 450 ceos signed
the black north pledge against
anti-black systemic racism taking aim at
unconscious bias and committing to the
creation of truly diverse teams 18
months later have those words translated
into action a kpmg poll of black
canadians in early january shows nearly
70 percent felt their employers were
making progress to create more inclusive
and equitable workplaces but but twelve
percent felt that what they were seeing
was lip service and one in five said
their employer was taking no action
84 percent want to establish targets for
hiring and promoting black canadians
with measurable outcomes and
accountability mechanisms and the same
number want to see more black
representation on boards of directors
and among management you always have to
be better and you always have to be the
best paulie watkiss says even though
she's climbed the corporate ladder in
her career a major challenge for her has
been imposter syndrome despite being
very qualified you're often in a room
where
you're the only woman of color you're
the only person of color sometimes and
in the automotive industry which is a
very white male dominated industry the
takeaway for employers across canada is
that progress has begun but the job is
far from done and the commitment needs
to be revisited regularly not just
during black history month you cannot
have
inclusive and diverse workforce and a
welcoming environment if
we don't have everybody sort of coming
along on that journey
equity in the workplace is a goal that
ultimately stands to benefit all workers
ann gaviola global news toronto
still ahead minimum age russia's
treatment of a 15 year old figure skater
sparks debate about teen athletes
and one of the premier events of those
winter olympics has renewed talk of a
minimum age requirement to compete in
the games this after a 15 year old
russian figure skater tested positive
for a banned substance struggled during
competition and then broke down while
the world watched mike trolley has more
hunched over the pain of the moment
seemed too great for russian skater
camilla valieva to handle she was
inconsolable and after her coach chose
to berate her ioc president thomas bach
gave a rare rebuke of russia when i
afterwards saw
how she was received by her closest
entourage
such a
what appeared to be a
a tremendous coldness
you you you
it was chilling
valieva had been the breakout star of
the games after becoming the first woman
to land a quadruple jump in the olympics
days later it was revealed she attested
positive for a banned substance but
controversially was still allowed to
skate by the court of arbitration for
sport which cited the potential for
irreparable harm to a 15 year old
now after her very public meltdown there
is renewed talk about a minimum age to
compete
it makes a lot of sense because even if
their bodies are able to do this
the psychological pressure the emotional
pressure is so high that a minor rarely
has the maturity and capacity to deal
with it especially if things go wrong
another russian skater 17-year-old
alexandra trusova won silver before
imploding off ice
everyone has a gold medal she said
everyone but not me i hate skating i
hate it i hate this sport i will never
skate again never
she explained her outburst by saying she
had done everything she could
there is an inordinate amount of
pressure in the olympics top u.s gymnast
simone biles was unable to compete in
parts of last summer's tokyo games
because of the stress to perform
the difference is that she was supported
by her coach and team
now some are saying bach's criticism of
russia alone isn't enough
many people have argued if they would
have been more strict with russia and
sent a more severe message and not
allowed them to compete at all we would
not have had this problem
and the bigger picture certainly needs
to be addressed but the immediate
concern is the mental health of a pair
of teenagers in over their heads
mike drolite global news toronto
coming up red cross refugee the story of
a syrian who's giving back to his
adopted home
northern british columbia is a world
away from syria but it's a place one
syrian refugee is now proud to call home
and to express his gratitude he's giving
back to his new community jay durant has
his story
with frost and his beard and the crunch
of snow underfoot hassan alcantara is
experiencing his first true canadian
winter hey buddy it's amazing because i
used to live in the desert in one of the
hottest spot on earth for the past eight
months hassan has been living in fort st
john enjoying everything northern bc has
to offer i love it when some canadians
call me and say well you are experienced
a part of canada we never did experience
before i lived at the airport for seven
months you may remember hassan's story
from 2018 a syrian refugee who spent
seven months at a malaysian airport
followed by two months in detention
before being privately sponsored for
asylum in canada i never doubted for a
moment
that we would get him here he was a
barista when he first arrived but
working with the red cross has been his
true calling so far his way of giving
back to the community and show canadians
they were not wrong in giving him this
chance because of them my life and maybe
my family's life will be changed forever
he has made many friends in canada but
is still very much alone his entire
family is still in syria he hasn't seen
them in 14 years and they want to know
everything about his new country did you
say they asked about tim hortons
yes
they know all about them haunts they are
i know all about maple syrup hassan
loves canada but not necessarily
everything that comes with it the
canadian beer i'm not a huge fan of that
i pretend that i love mabel sir but i
don't actually
but this past winter he has seen the
northern lights and his first moose
these are the canadian experiences he
never could have imagined he holds out
hope as impossible as it may seem that
maybe one day his family will too
to bring my family one day to live to
join me and i dream about that and that
one day i will wake up in the morning
and have a cup of coffee with my mother
or my siblings jay durant global news
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm jeff semple we leave you
tonight with one final look at the
situation in ottawa we'll continue to
follow this story as it develops through
the weekend hope to see you back here
again tomorrow thanks for watching and
have a great night